oder da was geht ab ihr sohn max und
herzlich willkommen zu diesem besonderen
video wir werden heute minecraft
woanders wann spielen allerdings nicht
stinknormal sondern mit controller hat
mir dafür ein kleines plugin installiert
und ich werde jetzt nur mit controller
worden was zu anzocken und gucken ob ich
da irgendwie eine chance habe oder ob
ich komplett untergehen werde
das hat gerade eben eher für komplett
untergehen gesprochen das kind war mäßig
so gut solche kleinen rating sache und
so was muss ich halt mit der hand machen
aber eigentlich muss ich sagen dieser
mord ist liebe school gemacht mit ok ich
glaube da hab ich jetzt nicht erst statt
wo ich weiß nicht wie im bogenschießen
wo ist das schwierig leute was das macht
sie selbstständig ich will auf 1 wir
kämpfen darum bloggt er jetzt ich hab
dachte da hab ich das ding gelobt gerade
okay da jetzt geht's los
gerade dadurch gesagt ich will das ding
cool aber ich habe jetzt gerade
herausgefunden dass das dass die blog
taste war und es ist absolut
es ist der absolute wahnsinn leute man
kann so maroni spiel okay wenn viel wenn
wir auch nur ein kampf gewinnen damit
dann feiere ich komplett nur ein leben
boah ist das überhaupt noch ist das
überhaupt nein ist ja kein schieden
hoffe ich zumindest ich hoffe mal dass
das budget ist und dass keiner sagt hey
du hast mit controller gespielt du hast
dir ein sehr unfairen vorteil verschafft
und na gut dass das nicht auch warum er
sprintet manchmal einfach rückwärts wird
warum springt ich denn da wirklich weil
dann wäre es natürlich ein hack
rückwärts springen sollte man ja in der
regel nicht kommen ja er gibt auch damit
habe ich meine ersten sieg mit
controller leute ich was ich das kit
fall nicht okay war jetzt nicht so
besonders vor ort eine angel gibt es
natürlich die hölle weil ich kann nicht
mit angel spielen ich kann mit dem
feiern nicht mehr lange spielen
warum passiert immer dieses rückwärts
sprinten das macht mich vollkommen
verrückt also leute wenn ihr wollt dass
daraus vielleicht so eine kleine kleine
serie wird ich probiere mit mäßigem
erfolg war das war knapp max probiert
mit mäßigem erfolg
irgendwie ansatzweise etwas zu reißen
mit dem controller
das wäre ein schöner serientitel dann
schreibt das doch bitte in die
kommentare
ich würde mich auf jeden fall freuen
falls ihr da bock drauf habt und würde
mein bestes geben dass ich irgendwie ein
bisschen besser werde
weil das kannte ich keine anschauen und
wenn das video hunderttausende schafft
dann spiele ich war mit 91 verspreche
ich weiß dass die ersten 100.000 live
stream wird aber ich befürchte dass
trotzdem leute sagen könnten echt voll
der laichzeit jugend etwas was diese
leute halt so sagen leute ich werde
extrem gut
ich hör auf es ist wirklich schwierig
man muss glaube ich vor gott es ist
wirklich lastet auf den controller aus
der kompromiss sehe aber er kommt mit in
die lava tm ist natürlich verstehen dass
das hauptsächlich jetzt als fan video
gemeint ist und ich euch mit dem
controller nicht irgendeine legendäre
neue methode zeigen möchte mit der man
in minecraft alles zerstören kann
sondern einfach nur zum fan video und
wir werden jetzt einfach mal ein
bisschen unserem bogen skills zu stellen
ist es irgendwie lustig man kann den
bogen so voll auf sparen und dann und
genauen plan kann man loslassen okay
leute das ist das ist jetzt gerade ich
noch ein bisschen sehr verpackt ich bin
echt noch etwas und talentiert warum
mache ich dieses video wenn ich nicht
kann sich jetzt auch einen rein
probieren irgendwie logisch
und umzukippen km springen kommt er
vielleicht bitte ich will einfach nur
gegen dich kämpfen ist es denn zu viel
verlangt okay kommt kommt kopfschutz
shipbuilding verstehe ich wie der
komplette nun aber ich spiele noch mit
kampf oder sonst wen ich dich besiegen
also du hast nämlich gerade echt nur
fans endlich aber du hast echt komisch
gespielt kopf bitte bitte bitte bitte wo
ist der titel
und jetzt kommt dieser ecke hinter ihre
bogenschuss kaum schießt doch schießt
doch mal
ich habe gerade getroffen
er lässt den bogen halt nicht los
irgendwie wisst ihr ich lade zu auf und
schießt irgendwie nicht so wie es mir
perfekt leute ist wird langer ich werde
ein richtiger profi ist wurde gerade
schon recht knapp ich habe den typen
fast geholt aber ich glaube ein
tatsächlicher sieg steht noch in den
sternen
vor warum sprintet dann einfach mal ist
es der typ kämpfen
ihr seht ihr ich habe diesen button
komplett vorgeschoben hat und er läuft
einfach in die wand rein das ist halt
die absolute kriege wenn man so spielt
ich möchte echt angel mal rausnehmen
aber wie gesagt die tastaturen es
irgendwie ein bisschen geblockt okay
jetzt überraschte mich wohl derselbe
reicht ihr sehr gut gemacht das packt er
bestimmt die angel aus ging an gewinns
weitgehend weitestgehend verloren
ich finde aber so richtig schlecht
schlagend mir nicht also ihr könnt das
liebend gerne ausprobieren
doch er sprintet 4
obwohl ich nichts mache okay leute das
ist jetzt unser aller letzter zeit
ich hoffe dass unser gegner irgendwie
nicht dazu kommt irgendwie zu cotton
oder so wir müssen probieren den
weitestgehend eine combo zu bringen was
wir nicht tun können da wir mit einem
verdammten controller spielen und der
typ ist extrem schnell im wasser
okay bin ich auch da wir hätten einfach
ein bisschen klavier habe irgendwie uns
gerade am leben erhalten
um jetzt in einem ehrenhaften kampf zu
sterben es war der absolute horror mit
controller zu spielen wenn ihr das
nochmal sehen wollt und denkt hey
vielleicht wird er besser beim nächsten
mal dann schreibt es in die kommentare
benötigt doch das hält sie nicht
anschauen schreibt auch dass in die
kommentare und da will ich sagen sie mir
vom diesmal wieder ich habe dadurch
gefallen
und bis dahin